so a bunch of questions for you sir if
someone has actually never seen anything
that you've done what is the first thing
you want them watching and why
oh my god uh probably sean of the dead
just because that was kind of near the
beginning near the inception of uh of
everything and um
it kind of sets out the stall quite
nicely i would yeah i guess that one
yeah
um which of the films you've been
involved with actually changed the most
in the editing room from what you
expected to what people saw
that's a good question i it's difficult
to say because i once you see the
finished film it's hard to remember the
original script sometimes you know what
i mean it sort of rewrites reality
um
i guess maybe ready player one perhaps
but maybe i'm thinking about the
differences between the book and the
script anyway but um you know the the
creation process is fluid it isn't like
you make a script you're constantly
making the movie when you when you shoot
the movie you then have a kind of visual
script which you then can also rewrite
and you rewrite that in the edit so
um
it's such a fluid process it's hard
sometimes to recall the stages of the
process if you know what i mean no
completely you are obviously very
talented writer uh but you have not
really directed a feature as far as i'm
aware and i'm wondering if that's on the
horizon for you
absolutely it's something i'd really
love to do and i i want to find the
right thing the idea of actually
spending some time
uh with a project more time than i would
do as an actor you know from from maybe
even the writing through to the
the pre-production production editing
all that is something i'm really keen to
do and i'm just
really waiting for something to pop up
that feels right it's got to be the
right thing i've been offered quite a
few things
um some of which i've developed um some
of which i haven't been right but yeah i
think i'll get there at some point
then edgar will give me the equal
of course uh i really enjoyed truth
seekers and i'm disappointed it didn't
get a second season had you and nick
like talked about what it would have
been
i think yeah i think there was kind of a
plan the the show was written mainly by
nat saunders and james sarafinowicz and
with nick and i kind of
weighing in nick more than me um so i
think there was a plan
but um
i don't know i mean these things happen
and uh
i wasn't massively disappointed to be
honest but there we go
got it uh i just enjoyed i enjoy
watching nick um
when you do a movie for disney plus does
that come with a lifetime subscription
you'd think
i mean i i you know i should i should i
should go for that recently i've been
watching a lot of i really enjoyed
dopesick you know the and and the
beatles documentary oh my god i mean it
was just transformative i loved it so
much um but no maybe i'm gonna get my
agent on this after thanks for making me
think of that steve listen uh also theme
park pass um what do you think it is
actually about the ice age franchise
because it's been going now for like 20
years what what has it been what do you
think it is about these characters in
this world that
so many people respond to
i think it's because in the very true
sense of the word they're family films
you know they're not only films which
can be watched by the whole family but
they are about a family and i i mean
that in a a genuine sort of
you know
that that word gets banded around a lot
particularly in ensemble uh uh sort of
uh films um but you have such different
characters and they've all got different
ideals and different
moral compasses in some ways and there's
the relationships between them a mirror
that of you know everyone's family
because everyone has
people in their family that they don't
get on with and annoy them and they love
beyond belief and all this kind of stuff
and i think the core of of the ice age
films is that and i think that obviously
appeals to people because you know the
vast majority of people do have a family
yes i'm going to accept that as fact um
you've obviously done four of these now
how has the recording process actually
is it has it always been the same on all
of these movies or has each film been a
little bit different in terms of you
know laying your voice down
well this one obviously was extremely
different just because of covert 19 and
although i did my first session i think
in a studio
every subsequent session i did at my
home
and um
you know a group of engineers would come
around they'd they'd set up the whole um
the the means by which to record and the
link with la and then i'd come down and
i'd i'd just do it from my house in this
very room you know so i would just
shuffle in here and you know not wearing
any pants and uh it was a perfect way to
go to work
i'm thinking
you know i've spoken a lot of people
that recording were recording voices for
different things in their closet
yeah well i have a room this might this
might this is my sort of movie room so
it's it's quite nice acoustics are great
it's got lots of acoustic paneling it's
it's essentially a screening room so
it's kind of perfect for voice servers
so i uh i i lucked out there so
this is i believe uh john's first
feature film uh the director and so i'm
curious what was he like to collaborate
with um because obviously first time you
know what i mean like i'm sure getting
the keys to the ferrari you know i'm
just curious what that was like
well i think because john's been
attached to the franchise for a long
time he knows the characters very well
you know this isn't someone who's come
in who's a complete stranger to it this
is someone who knows the universe knows
the dynamic um and knows you know how
how everyone behaves and he was great he
had firm ideas and
it's it's it's always a collaboration
when you do animation
in so much as you're
you know
you're providing one part of of what's
seen and then the animators do another
and as always the director you know sort
of steers the ship so
um he felt like uh uh you know a very
solid and kind of uh inventive captain
to me
for people that are actually not
familiar with making an animated movie
what do you actually think might
surprise them to learn about the actual
filmmaking process
yeah it's the the the process begins
with all the audio you know that's what
i think
people tend to think that the animation
happens and then people do the voice to
the animation but of course you need to
to grow everything from the audio and so
you see animatics and you see concept
designs and you hear about ideas for
sequences and of course you read the
script
but what happens is you'll record all of
your uh vocals and then the animators
will listen to the vocals watch the
video of you during the session to get
inspiration for facial expressions and
um and then the animation is grown on
top of that and then you come back and
you you adapt and you know it becomes
very much a back and forth kind of
process but the whole thing begins with
the voices
uh you have been able to do a lot of
cool stuff in your career what is one of
the things that you still can't believe
you got to do just as like a geek of
nerdum you know what i mean like someone
who is a fan of hollywood
probably the short period of time that i
owned the millennium falcon
that's probably
that's probably up there i mean aside
from being the chief engineer on the
starship enterprise that wasn't my ship
do you know what i mean that was jim's
he he was the boss but i actually had
the log book and the ownership papers of
the millennium falcon for however long
it was maybe a couple of months but
that's on my resume now and it's not
going anywhere
i yeah uh
are you obviously uh are you watching
the mandalorian and book of boba fett is
that something that you're doing yeah i
i yeah i absolutely am tuning in
uh what are your thoughts on it because
i'll just say that i think john and dave
have been doing a phenomenal job
it's it's like catnip for star wars fans
you know it's really really particularly
you know fans of that era of star wars
you know it's it's all set round about
the time when we all fell in love with
that universe and
just sort of seeing
that
world i mean that universe expanded
is is a delight you know it's um
it's really good but i think they've
done a very good job of creating
something which is very stripped back i
think in other areas of star wars things
got very complex and sort of and busy
and i think with these
shows um they've been really good at a
bit of showing extreme restraint and you
know like the last episode of uh of boba
fett was was just a heist a train heist
you know it's like a western and i think
that that that that that goes that
speaks to how you know star wars started
out was very simple
yeah um the undeclared war sounds pretty
cool uh and i'm curious what can you
tease people about it for people that
aren't familiar with it
i'm really really excited this is a
series that i've done for uh peacock and
for channel 4 here in the uk uh it's
written by peter kuzminski who's a
multi-award-winning writer it's myself
mark rylance um um adrian lester alex
jennings it's a a thriller about a cyber
attack on the uk
from possibly from russia and um it's
just a really gripping exciting
um very very realistic um drama series
and it was lovely to kind of flex some
different muscles and and do something
different you know for me it was a real
treat to be
away from the geek verse and the comedy
verse doing something you know
like that no completely uh obviously
like the entire planet i could not be
more excited for a certain mission
impossible movies i guess i'll say uh
two films
what are you what are you allowed to say
uh about the next two installments
benji dies
uh true by the way
it could be an elaborate double bluff
you just never know
it's um it's it's
as as is always the case you know and i
think this is down to mccue and tom just
feeling the need to just ratchet it up
every time and you know we just finished
filming one
where tom did some insane things which
you know i was there for and
terrified during because you just don't
know if it's gonna
you know be successful
and now we're moving on to the next one
where things have been you know pumped
up again and we always joke about it at
the end of every film well what are you
gonna do now
and i can never imagine where we're
gonna go because it's like well we can't
do anything more crazy than hanging off
a plane and yet then in in fallout you
know
he does what he did in that and then in
the new one he
it just gets crazier and crazier so i'm
i'm stoked for it to be
you got to remember though we have to
watch it when it's happening which is is
even more gripping
i i think that tom deserves an oscar for
what he does for these movies uh like no
joke he it's unbelievable what he's
willing to do to make the best possible
movie
i think in the service of cinema
absolutely and in an era where anything
is possible digitally you know and and
obviously beautifully done and um it's
incredible to see the idea that the
person you're watching is doing the
thing that you're watching is isn't as
common as it used to be and now with uh
you know thomas kind of
has really has has really gone to town
with that whole you know the stunt
surreal thing
yeah uh last question for you or last
subject uh obviously i'm kind of a star
trek fan i think you know that uh no
really
yes we've never spoken about it before
ever uh have you spoken actually to matt
uh about uh this next star trek movie
like what what do you know what can you
say
i don't know much i i've met matt
briefly and seems like a great guy i
love the work he did on one division and
uh you know
it's just um
it's always waiting in with these things
you know because the the the world is is
an uncertain place covert's thrown
everything into a spin
um there's so many factors that have to
to to align in order for these things to
happen um i'm just quietly
um waiting for news basically and uh i
texted jj the other day and said
tell me what's happening and you know
he's just like we're waiting for news so
i i i understand look i love the fact
that star trek is it seems like it's
really exploding with all the content uh
yeah right
yeah and i'd love to see you know more
adventures in the kelvin universe and
obviously any chance i get to work with
those actors is um
i'll leap at it you know it'll be it's
going to be a little sad this time but
um you know stay tuned
on that note uh thank you for your time
and
hope you and your family are all doing
okay
you too nice to see you i wasn't at all
distracted by all those lovely things
behind you by the way
you